[Applause]
what the [ __ ] is
the blockchain i need to know what this
is he keeps laughing he don't
you gotta go let it go yeah so uh let's
start with blockchain technology yeah
blockchain technology was created to
solve a problem called the double spin
problem so you gotta understand the
problem to understand the solution
if uh i create uh music and i put it out
in a digital format it's a music file
right you have the music file and you're
listening to show you're like damn pop
is a [ __ ]
banger yeah andrew wants it he's like yo
send me the song you hit
send when you hit send the computer
program creates a copy
sends him the song he's now listening to
my song but you still have my song as
well you both can listen
you're both happy you're like yo we
could listen to the cool song right but
you
and you don't know who has the original
and who has the copy all you know is you
got a file you got a file
that's fine when it's music that's fine
when it's a photo that's fine when it's
all these things
that it doesn't matter about scarcity
but with money
if i have a [ __ ] digital dollar and
you say send me the dollar
and i send you it and now you got it and
i got it well who's got the dollar
who's got the real who's got the
counterfeit we don't know and so
there's been a bunch of people over the
years who have tried to create digital
currency but this has been the big
problem is the
file can be replicated easily and you
can't prove what the original is
so that's called a double spin problem
he could send it to you and then send it
to me
and we both think we got the dollar but
actually we just got copies and he still
has the dollar
seems like a problem isn't this how
banking works to a certain extent
let's not go there but i i don't want to
spend too much time but isn't that the
whole idea of like if the bank
only needs to keep ten percent of the
reserves in the bank
and there's a hundred thousand dollars
can't you lend out 90 to him and now you
just made a hundred and ninety
well you just made well no thousand
dollars out of nowhere so there's
leverage there's all this complexity but
basically what they're doing in that
situation is they're not creating new
currency
what they're doing is they're bar
they're borrowing it or you're
depositing it with them and they're
lending it on the back end and they're
doing all this stuff but technically is
it your money is it an iou that they
have
you've made more out of nowhere no
because you gave them some money then
there's
leverage they can borrow they can do all
that stuff the the key to this
is counterfeit versus original i
understand that right i understand i
just i just think that the idea of like
printing money isn't that novel because
like if you're
if you're oh banks want to be central
banks we can get into that no no no no
no
let's keep sleeping but like let's say i
give you a hundred thousand dollars to
keep in your bank your bank of america
and
he wants a loan you could give him
ninety thousand dollars to my hundred
thousand dollars but i can get my
hundred thousand whenever i want and he
can get his 90 whenever he wants you
just made 90 000 out of nowhere
so when you give me the money a lot of
people don't know this it's not your
money anymore
what when you deposit the money in the
bank it's not your money
they they have an iou they owe you a
hundred thousand dollars but technically
it's their money now
oh [ __ ] oh yeah yeah you pump all right
let's get back to blockchain ready
okay so that's a fact so you're ready
yeah that's fact so look here here's the
whole idea of a blockchain is
uh if we sit down and uh blockchain
verifies the original
at a very high level but here's how it
works let's say we go to play monopoly
is the best way to describe it
four of us sit down to play monopoly and
uh with monopoly there's a bank
and then each of us have the money in
the game and we set it out in front of
us
right and the way the reason why
monopoly works is because as we are
doing transactions
you owe him money bam i see you hand him
the 200 he hands me the money right all
the stuff
we don't need a fifth person to stand
over us and act as the banker or the
centralized entity
who does all the transactions because
there's full transparency
right if you ever play with a kid and
they put the money under the table
you're like yo yo get that [ __ ] up here
like i don't know what the [ __ ] you're
doing but i don't trust you right
so when the money's uh transparently put
on the table and then all the
transactions happen in front of
everybody
we all don't have to trust that it's
being done correctly we can verify it i
saw you give them the 200
yeah yeah yeah so a blockchain basically
is if we were playing that game
and we had a piece of paper and i wrote
down every transaction right i said you
know i gave andrew two hundred dollars
right you here so it's a ledger ledger
but every 10 minutes
i ripped off the piece of paper and i
put it to the side i said all right that
was the first 10 minutes of the game
that's all the transactions that
happened
and then all of a sudden we say played
for the next 10 minutes started a new
piece of paper did it again
bam done i rip off that piece i stack it
on top of the first 10 minutes
we keep playing we've been playing for
15 minutes now there's five pieces of
paper sitting over here and you go you
know what
i think that you owe me thirty dollars i
said no actually
in minute thirty two let me go back to
the transactions and i can show you
that i gave you that 30 already that's
essentially what a blockchain does
but rather than it be on paper what it
does is every 10 minutes
it takes all of the transactions that
happen on the block on the
bitcoin network and it basically puts it
into a block so it's literally just to
give it almost like in an
overgeneralized way uh uh
excel file right of all the transactions
and then there's people who run the
network
they validate yep looks good and as long
as more than 51
of people validate it they chain the
block
of transactions to the last one and it
goes all the way back to the beginning
so from january 3rd 2009 you can go back
on a blockchain and see every single
transaction that's ever happened in this
network
so it's literally blocks of transactions
that are chained together
bitcoin block potentially really stupid
question is that hackable
so uh can it ever be hacked
any computer network quote unquote could
be hacked the probability that it gets
hacked is
near zero because it is the strongest
computing network in the world
and the whole idea uh behind the bitcoin
network is that it's decentralized yes
so when we talked about is playing
monopoly if there was a fifth person who
was like
the boss of the game then that would be
like the centralized that'd be like the
bank right
and so today if i want to send money to
one of you through the u.s system
a bank says i'm going to debit pomp's
account and i'm going to credit andrews
right
yeah but if what if we don't need them a
peer-to-peer i just want to send it to
you i don't i don't want anyone else to
[ __ ] with it i want to just send it to
you
so decentralization means that there's
nowhere to hack it 51
consensus in order to put it on the
blockchain
yes what is that 51 of whom
so the way that it works is um there's
miners around the world this goes to
decentralization so if there's not a
centralized company that owns this thing
who runs it
well there's people running the software
they have specialized computers they
give it like a data center
right they plug them in and what they're
doing is they're they're running all
these computations
super complex process we don't need to
go into what they're doing exact
problems right solving problems get
rewarded for solving the problems
there's a financial incentive so every
10 minutes in the beginning 50 bitcoin
were given out to the network
and if you were running computers you
had a chance to get
some of those 50 bitcoin every 10
minutes if you solve enough problems
you get rewarded for the get rewarded
gotcha azure you know more than you're
letting on
as you're doing this what ends up
happening is
uh that went on for four years every 10
minutes for four years 50 bitcoin
after four years programmatically
meaning it was written into the code
it cut from 50 to 25. so what happens if
you have a
fixed supply yeah yeah and demand keeps
going up and the supply
incoming supply drops the [ __ ] price
goes up
correct me if i'm wrong here uh now that
there's less
are there more problems that you
essentially have to solve in order to
access
a new bit of coin in other words does
the processing go
up to mine a new coin it it so
uh along with the in a way the better
way i think people
that are kind of learning about all this
to think about it is the more
competition there is
yeah for the bitcoin reward yeah uh the
more work you have to do
yep the other thing is that there's less
bitcoin so went from 50 to 25 25 to 12
and a half 12 to now 6.25
eventually get cut in half again in
about three and a half years
um and this is to maintain value along
with demand
think about uh visa when visa runs the
transaction
or you know the visa network yeah we pay
for it we and the merchants pay for to
use the system
all of that revenue goes on to a
centralized p l right
like into their bank account it sits
there and if you're a visa shareholder
that's part of your money
yeah well when you have a decentralized
entity where does that go
the transaction fees plus this bitcoin
reward basically gets distributed
on a uh across all these people running
the network
so you today could go become a
quote-unquote owner in a sense
right of a portion of the revenue of the
bitcoin network
you got to go get a computer you plug it
in you point it to this network you
start running the software
and now all of a sudden you're one of
millions of miners around the world
and every time a new person joins to get
part of this revenue
it becomes more and more decentralized
which means that whether it's the
government whether it's a hacker whether
it's whoever
they have to basically penetrate
everybody they can't just
or 51 of people right they can't just
penetrate your computer or your computer
they got to get more of the control of
the network and that's what makes it so
secure and my understanding is that it
takes an immense amount of processing
power to mine for this bitcoin a ton
a ton it's the strongest computing
network in the world meaning if you take
all the computing power that's pointed
at this thing and running the software
yes
it's by far the strongest network in the
[Applause]
world
you